both mean absolute error and mean
squared error
a popular metrics but they're not bonded
in a fixed range
so it's not possible to compare across
data sets
next we'll introduce another regression
metrics called are squared which has a
fixed maximum score of one
formally our squared or coefficient of
determination is one minus the ratio
between mse
and variance for example if we have a
linear regression model looking like
this the mean square error can be equal
to 0.86
while the variance equals 4.9 and are
squared for this particular example is
around 0.82
which is considered to be very good in
fact our squared of one
indicate the regression is perfectly
fits data while our squared of zero
indicate the line does not fit the data
at all
it is important to notice that by this
definition it's possible to have
negative values of r squared
which means the predictive model
performed worse than a simple average
over the original data
again the same visual illustration as we
increase the noise level
we can see the r-squared value also
decreases